ما يحدث حيث
أنتم لستم من الشرطة ، ما هي الوكالة التي أنتم جميعًا
من رجل
[موسيقى]
كيف تبدو حياتي هنا
ليس لدي ثقة في هذه الحكومة ، أنا
لست
[موسيقى]
لا أفعل  لدي إيمان برئيسي ،
فأنا لا أؤمن بالنظام ،
فأنا أتعامل مع نظام معطل
غير مصمم لأشخاص مثلي ،
أصدقائي ،
كانت والدتي أستاذة في علم الاجتماع ،
كان والدي مشرفًا على
سلطة النقل في بروكلين ،
كما تعلمون  لكن والدي كان مدمنًا على الكحول
عندما كان عندما حاول أن يصبح
عنيفًا وأنا أعلم أنه سئم ، لذلك أطلقت النار عليه
فوق ركبتيه ،
كما تعلم
أنني ارتكبت فعلًا عنيفًا آخر عندما
اغتصب رجل ابن عمي البالغ من العمر 13 عامًا ،
فقتله في وضح النهار  2 30
بعد الظهر ،
أمضيت 10 سنوات في السجن بسبب
[الموسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لذا
[موسيقى
] حسنًا يا سيدي ، أعياد سعيدة ، ليلة سعيدة ،
اسمي بول ألكساندر ، أبلغ من العمر 51
عامًا وأنا بلا مأوى في نيويورك  المدينة منذ
عام 2008.
هناك كل شيء على ما يرام يا سيدي عطلة سعيدة ،
أليس كذلك يا سيدتي أي شا  استمتع
بعطلة سعيدة بكابوس 250 دولارًا في اليوم
في يوم جيد يمكنني أن أجني 300. لكن
هذه 18 ساعة لأعلى ولأسفل
18 ساعة متتالية لأعلى
ولأسفل على قدمي ،
كل شيء على ما يرام في عطلة نهاية أسبوع واحدة ، حسنًا ،
أعطني سيدي إيمي  jp
شكرًا لك سيدي ، عطلات سعيدة ، حسنًا ، لقد
دخنت 60 سيجارة في اليوم ، فأنا لا
أتخلص من الكوكايين ،
فأنا في تيارات متقاطعة بين نظام
مكسور يتعلق بالربح أكثر من
الطبيعة البشرية
[الموسيقى]
نحن قادمون من  أسرة مكونة من ثمانية أفراد والفقر
عندما كنت أذهب إلى المدرسة ، اعتدت
أن أرتدي
بنطلين لارتداء بنطلون واحد لأعلى ،
كنت فقيرًا للغاية ، لكنني أردت أن أخرج نفسي
من الفقر الكامل لك
أعلم أنني أردت أن أحقق حياة أفضل
لنفسي ،
فأنا لا أحب الفقر ، لقد كرهت
الفقر ، لقد نذرت لنفسي إذا وصلت يومًا
إلى مكان يمكنني فيه كسب بعض
المال وارتداء ملابس جيدة ،
فسأفعل
ذلك ، إنه صف انزلاقي  من المشهور
أن يجمع الأشخاص حياتهم معًا
وسيحصلون على شخصين أو ثلاثة
نحن جميعًا
بما فيهم أنا لأنني أقوم بإجراء
مقابلة [الموسيقى] ،
لا يحب الناس الكاميرات مثل هذه في
إيمانهم
لأنهم يفترضون أنك
إما الشرطة أو الرامي سيكون
في الصحيفة ،
هناك أشخاص مختلفون هنا  لأسباب مختلفة ،
فقدوا وظيفة أو فقدوا منزلًا ، بغض النظر عن
العذر
الذي يأتون إليه هنا للالتقاء ببعضهم
البعض ،
أعتقد أن المشكلة الأساسية التي
نواجهها جميعًا في أي
حالات من الفقر هي مجرد
الافتقار إلى المجتمع مثل
الافتقار إلى الأسرة.  إن الافتقار إلى الدعم من حولك ،
سانت لويس يشبه إلى حد كبير الكثير من
المدن الأمريكية الأخرى
من بعض النواحي ، فهو لا يزال منفصلاً للغاية ، حيث
كان لديك الكثير من الأشخاص الذين لا يكفيهم
الدفع مقابل مكان للعيش فيه
للأحياء الفقيرة في جميع المناطق التي
نذهب
إلى حيث يقيم الكثير من الأشخاص
المشردين ، اعتاد هذا أن يكون مخيمًا كبيرًا
للمشردين هنا
أه ولكن المدينة التي دمرتها جميعًا
كان بها عدد قليل من الأشخاص الذين
اشتعلت فيها النيران في خيامهم وماتوا كما
تفعل
حسنًا ، دعنا نفعل ذلك ،
أتمنى لو كانت هناك كلمة أفضل
من أن تكون بلا مأوى لأنني أعتقد
أن هذه ليست المشكلة الوحيدة التي يواجهها بعض
الناس
سواء كان لديك منزل أم
أنك لست أشخاصًا لطيفين وأشخاص لطيفين وما
إذا كنت  لديك منزل حيث لا يوجد لديك
بعد ذلك ، فهم حمقى وهناك
أشخاص
يمكن أن يكونوا عنيفين وعدوانيين
سواء كان لديك منزل أم لا ،
ما زلت تتصرف بنفس الطريقة
التي لدينا عربات طعام فيها  مدينة نيويورك في
كل مكان
يطلقون عليها عربات الجيروكارت وعربات الحوائط الجافة
لديك الجيروسكوبات ولديهم
أرز
لحم الضأن مع الأرز والدجاج والأرز والخضروات المختلطة
شيش كباب على العصا ولديهم بعض
الطعام الجيد جدًا
ولكني عادة ما آكل  الكثير من البيتزا
لأن هناك شرائح بالدولار ،
لذا فهي رخيصة ، لم أعد أتناول الطعام الصيني
بعد الآن ، أنا فقط أتناول الكثير من تلك
الأشياء ، لم أعد أفعل ذلك بعد الآن ،
أحب لحم الضأن والأرز
، فأنا بحاجة إلى
الألياف وهو رجل أكبر سنًا تعرفه
وتعيش على
أنا بحاجة إلى هذا النوع من الطعام لأتناوله ،
ويجب أن أحصل دائمًا على خضرواتي
لأن الخضروات بها فيتامينات ،
كما تعلم ، أعني أنه ليس كما لو أنني ذاهب
إلى السير الذاتية كل يوم حيث يمكنني
تحمل شرائك تعرف سنتروم  الرجال 50.
أنت تعلم أنني لا أفعل ذلك
[موسيقى]
حسنًا
، من فضلك مع كبير ماك واحد من فضلك
مع وسيط ، أعني أنك تريد وجبة
ليس مجرد رجل كبير ، فالأمر الكبير على
ما يرام  لدي ذلك واسمحوا لي
أن أحصل
على شاي متوسط الحجم خفيف وشاي حلو مت
سط الحجم.  افعل
ذلك لا يعمل بهذه الطريقة كما تعلم
أه لأنه عندما يجب عليك الذهاب إلى
الحمام ، ستواجه الكثير من
المتاعب
عندما تعيش في الشارع عليك
استخدام الحمام بشكل صحيح ولا يمكنك
استخدام  الحمام
يا إلهي
واحد اثنان
اشترينا شاحنة بوكس قديمة على ال
نترنت وأه حولها إلى ما لد
نا اليوم دش محمول إي
ا وبي بي شا
ر  كنت أتطوع مع مجموعة كانت
بها شاحنة طعام
، وها أنا قفزت وبدأت
التطوع على طاولة
والاعتناء ببعض مواد النظافة ،
كان لدى صديق لي هنا في سانت لويس
صالون وأعطتني بعض
الشامبو باهظ الثمن حقًا
وأه  كان الأمر كما لو كنت تعرف أربعين
دولارًا من
الزجاجة التي أعطيتها لهذا الرجل المحترم وقلت
هنا إن هذا شامبو باهظ الثمن حقًا
وقال شكرًا لك لكنني
لم أجد مكانًا لاستخدامه
وكان ذلك محرجًا للغاية وعارًا.
لقد كنت متحمسًا جدًا لتوزيع
الشامبو على شخص ما ، لكنني لم أفكر
كثيرًا في أنه لن يكون لديهم مكان
لاستخدامه ، ولذا فكرت في أنه
إذا صنعنا شاحنات طعام
وأنت تعلم إذا وضعنا مطابخ
داخل شاحنة ، فلماذا  لا يمكننا وضع الدش
داخل شاحنة وبدء
العملية برمتها من هناك ، من
الجيد رؤيتك جيدًا لرؤيتك
مرة أخرى ،
نعم حوالي أسبوع
[موسيقى]
عندما كنت في العاشرة من عمري اكتشفت أنني
أستطيع الغناء
قليلاً  قليلا ولم يكن هناك انسجام لذلك بعض
الرجال أنا  علمني الحي كيفية
المواءمة وشكلنا مجموعة أنا
وأخي وشخصين آخرين حصلنا على
فرقتنا وقمنا بعروض المواهب المحلية في
المدارس وفي النوادي الليلية في ممفيس
[موسيقى]
كنا نجمًا محليًا  الموهبة التي تعرفها في
مدينة ممفيس
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، لقد رأينا أشياء تخص كل شخص آخر كما
تعرف الرجال الذين لديهم سجلات بالفعل
كنا جيدين جدًا ونغني أغنياتهم
التي تعرفونها حتى لا يضطروا إلى
الخروج والعمل هكذا  بجد لذلك
أعطانا الجزء الأول من
الساعة وغنينا يا رجل ، لقد سقطنا للتو يا رجل ،
سنخطو
كما تعلمون ، كما تعلمون ، سنكون حادين تمامًا مثل هذا
هنا كما تعلمون
، ثم كنت أنا فقط المغني الرئيسي
لذلك أنا  كنت في بوستا بو
، وربما غنيت شيئًا مثل
الأغنية التي سمعتها جميعًا
يا فتاتي
ذات القضبان ، لا شيء مشابه للأفكار التي لم يتم حلها
.  يأخذ الواقع البشري في النهاية
فضاء العاطفة
e ويذكرني بأن تحذير الدموع
سيبقيني في مكاني
متحدين ولن يتم هزيمته أبدًا
[موسيقى] ،
لذا فهذه مهمة إنقاذ الإفطار يوم الأحد ،
نحن أكبر مزود خدمة مجانية
للوجبات في فيلادلفيا ،
نحن مقدم الخدمة المجاني الوحيد
للإفطار  في المدينة بأكملها
[موسيقى]
نقدم 400 وجبة في اليوم وبغض النظر
عما
يتضمن دائمًا الإفطار والغداء والعشاء ،
فنحن نقدم أيضًا حوالي 180 شخصًا
كل ليلة يحتاجون فقط إلى مكان
للنوم
[موسيقى]
كل سرير فردي في هذه الغرفة
يوجد
حاليًا وسادة عليها ، إنه في الواقع شخص مادي
حجز هذا السرير
الليلة ، لذا كما ترون ، نحن في الحقيقة
شبه مكتمل تمامًا
لمهمة إنقاذ الإفطار يوم الأحد ،
يبلغ عمرها 139 عامًا ، لذلك كان هناك عدد غير
قليل من الأشخاص المشردين في فيلادلفيا
في ذلك الوقت
لقد كان ذلك قبل فترة طويلة من الكساد الكبير ،
ومع ذلك كان هناك
وباء كبير جدًا للمشردين في
فيلادلفيا ،
ولا نتلقى أي تمويل حكومي ،
وهذا يعني أننا
مستقلون تمامًا  معلقة من السلاسل التي قد
تأتي
مع قبول أي أموال من
الحكومة ،
نقوم بذلك لأننا لا
نريد بالضرورة السلاسل ولكن أيضًا إذا كانت هناك
تخفيضات ضخمة في الميزانية كما
كانت قبل بضع سنوات ،
فإننا في الواقع لا نحصل عليها  تأثرت لأن
لدينا كامل تدفق الإيرادات
من الأفراد الذين يتبرعون لنا
بالمال بدلاً من ذلك من
خلال شيء
يمكن تغييره بسهولة مثل السياسة
[الموسيقى] ،
لذلك في السنوات القليلة الماضية في أمريكا ،
واجهنا صعوبة كبيرة في
تمرير
ميزانيتنا  هذا يعني أنه كان لدينا
بالفعل بضعة أسابيع
حيث يتم إغلاق حكومتنا
لأننا لا نستطيع تجاوز الأمر
الذي أصبح يمثل مشكلة كبيرة
للأشخاص الذين يعتمدون على هذا المال ،
الشكر
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا لك
الآن
يا شارع 34 الآن
حسنًا ، لقد حصلنا على رئيس بلدية
، لقد وعدنا هو وزوجته
بإسكان المرضى عقليًا
والمشردين ، وهذا لم يحدث حقًا
[موسيقى]
لدي نجار يجلس على 20 مليار
دولار
سور  بالإضافة إلى الإسكان الميسور التكلفة لم
يؤتي ثماره إلا لخمسة
والشيء الوحيد الذي أراه تم بناؤه هنا هو
المزيد من الفنادق ،
حسنًا ،
أنت تعلم أنني أعيش في الشارع ،
هناك الكثير من الأشخاص المشردين يعيشون في
الشارع
ولكن يمكن نقلنا  إذا كانت
الحكومة
أو بعض رفاقي المواطنين
سيصعدون ويطالبون المسؤولين الحكوميين
بإدخال هذا وإنفاق الأموال في
الأماكن
المناسبة لإبعاد الناس عن الشارع لأنه في
مرحلة ما
عليك مساعدة الأشخاص الذين لا يستطيعون مساعدة
أنفسهم  الكثير منها مجرد حقيقة مؤسفة
مفادها أن معظم الناس في فيلادلفيا على
بعد حوالي
اثنين من رواتبهم من التشرد ،
وهذا يعني أنه ليس لديك وظيفة لمدة
أربعة أسابيع
ثم فجأة ستصبح
بلا مأوى لأنك  تعيش حرفيًا
من الراتب إلى الراتب ، فأنت
بحاجة
إلى الوظيفة التالية من أجل الاستمرار في
دفع الإيجار
، وإذا لم تدفع الإيجار ، فسيتم طردك
من وجهة نظري ، وأعتقد حقًا
أن طريق أم إلى التشرد
في فيلا  الدلافين هي حقيقة أن
هناك عددًا كبيرًا جدًا من السكان أه تحت
خط الفقر
الكثير من الناس إذا خسرت شيكين من
الراتب ، فلن يكون
هذا أمرًا كبيرًا ولكن في فيلادلفيا
يعد هذا أمرًا كبيرًا للغاية لحوالي
من  عدد السكان
يمكن لأي شخص أن يصبح بلا مأوى كثير من
الناس يصبحون بلا مأوى بسبب
نوع من الأحداث الكارثية في حياتهم ،
ربما كانت الفاتورة الطبية مرتفعة جدًا
أو
قد يتسبب الطلاق أو شيء من هذا القبيل في
التشرد
[موسيقى]
تعال يا فتى ، هيا ، تعال ،
آسف ،
كيف حالك ، إنها عطلة سعيدة
، حقًا ، أحظى بمباركة ،
كيف حالك جيدًا يا رجلي ،
بارك الله فيك ،
لقد ولدت في كلية بروكلين نيويورك ، لقد
تخرجت من درجة الماجستير و  درجة البكالوريوس ،
أنا أتخرج من المدرسة ،
كنت مستشارًا للزواج لمدة 17 عامًا
من حياتي
العسكرية السابقة
عندما توفيت زوجتي بسبب
سرطان الثدي في عام
2006 ، وتوفي جزء مني معها
[موسيقى
] بدأت وحيدا للغاية  بدأت أصوات آرينغ
بارتكاب محاولات انتحار
وبدأت في الشرب وتعاطي المخدرات بشكل يومي
وطوّرت عادة مخدرات سيئة للغاية
ومشكلة عقلية من
ورائها ،
لكنني لست مريضًا بدرجة كافية لبرامج الصحة العقلية
وبرامج الأدوية لا تريدني
لأنني  من تاريخ صحتك العقلية ،
أبدو عنيفًا ،
فأنا لست شخصًا عنيفًا ، على الرغم من أنني أعني أنني
أستطيع أن أصبح عنيفًا للغاية عندما يتعين
علي أن أكون ،
أريد استعادة حياتي معًا ، لقد
سئمت من العيش في الشارع الذي
كنت أعرفه  هذه فترة طويلة جدًا ،
لم أكن أرغب أبدًا في المساعدة حقًا ، كان لدي
الكثير من محاولات الانتحار ، حسنًا ، لقد
عدت إلى الله وعاد إلى
الكنيسة وأعاد حياتي إلى الله ،
أحاول أن أكون أفضل شخص يمكنني أن
أكون ثانية فيه  في وقت في اليوم في المرة ،
ليس الأمر سهلاً دائمًا ، فأنا إنسان
أحيانًا أخطأ ، وأرتكب أخطاء تعرفها
ولكني أحتاج إلى مساعدة وأنا أعلم أنني لا أستطيع فعل
ذلك بنفسي ،
لقد حاولت عدة مرات  فهم
ما يمرون
به ويمكنني أن أجعل حياتهم قليلاً
أصبح وجه المشردين أكثر راحة
ولديك منصة وصوت
للمشردين ودعهم يعرفون أن
المظهر هو حقًا شيء غير
أناني ترك شيئًا أنانيًا لأنه في الحقيقة
لم يعد يتعلق بي بعد الآن
، كل شيء يتعلق بأنك تعرف ما الذي يمكنني فعله
لأفعله  حياة أفضل بالنسبة لشخص
آخر مر بهذه التجربة بنفسي ،
هناك مكان
يأسرك
[الموسيقى]
وتسمع القرية تسمع
[موسيقى]
تلتقط
هناك مباشرةً
[موسيقى]